La volta al món a peu, catalans sense fronteres, però avui també valencians sense fronteres.
Aquí tinc el meu taxi que m'acompanyarà a conèixer aquest valencià que viu a Caixgar.
Sí, sí, sí, sí, molt loco.
L'altre dia vaig posar un riddle dient que estava aquí a Caixgar, a la Xina, tal,
i bueno, em va escriure un noi que es diu Daniel, ara el coneixerem,
que diu, jo visc a Caixgar, com pot ser això?
No m'esperava trobar cap català, ni valencià, ni ningú que parlés el meu idioma
que visqués aquí, en aquest lloc tan perdut de la Xina.
Llavors he agafat un taxi per anar fins a la seva zona, a la zona on viu,
on viu la gent, no aquí al centre, que és com més turístic,
i que m'expliqui què hi fa aquí, perquè és un lloc molt raro per viure.
Doncs una part de la ciutat molt diferent, sense cases grans, aquí, cases baixes,
també és interessant de veure això, però clar, t'estàs picant al centre que després no,
mira, allà està el Daniel, t'estàs picant al centre que per aquí no veus,
per aquí no hi ha atraccions turístiques.
Hola!
Què tal?
Molt bé.
Daniel o Xina, eh?
Sí.
Mira, té.
Un micròfon.
Perfecte.
On anem? On em portes?
Anem cap allà.
Cap allà.
A un restaurant, sí.
I dinem.
Molt bé.
Hola.
Són les dotze i pico.
Jo sempre pregunto...
Són la una i quart.
Una i quart.
Sí.
Sempre pregunto quina hora hi segueix aquí la gent, perquè per una part són aquesta hora,
però és hora de Pequín.
Sí, és hora de Pequín.
Així la gent comença a moure's ben tard.
Com a les onze, deu, onze, la gent comença a menejar-se.
Que vindria a ser l'equivalent a les set.
A les vuit del matí.
Del matí, clar.
Són la una, que serien les deu, i em portes a dinar.
Això també és raro.
Això és.
De fet, jo que soc, podem dir, addicte al cafè, de bon matí, no hi ha ningú un cafè obert.
No hi ha.
És impossible.
T'has d'esperar a, doncs això, deu i mitja, a onze, per poder demanar el cafè.
Sí.
Però bueno.
Bona nit.
Deix...
Volem menjar...
Això que no dines normalment, a part d'avui.
A la una o dotze i mitja.
Ostres.
A mi depèn de la feina.
Quan parem, quan tinc un poquet de...
Quan tinc un poquet de temps lliure, doncs dinem.
I en el dia no esmorzes?
Cafè i poquet.
Vale, vale.
Sí que hi ha alguna tendeta, a la millor oberta, de molt pronte, que tenen com el seu panet
en cardins, que es diu pausa, que ells diuen com pausa, que està molt bo.
I això sí que ho fas ràpid, ho pots agafar i després el fas amb un te o algun cafè
i pots esmorzar.
D'on ets?
Soc del Baida.
Això on està?
Està...
Per Alcoi.
Igual sí que desona on tinguem entre Alcoi, a 30 minuts de Gandia, una hora de València,
una hora d'Alacant.
D'acord.
Comarca de l'Albaida Albaida.
Molt bé.
I aquest barri seria una mica un barri guai?
No sé, només està pel centre, bàsicament.
Sí, jo crec que...
No sé què podria ser el barri guai.
Allà, ara sí, després d'anar-hi podem anar...
Hi ha una anòria, hi ha un llac on es pot passejar.
Però és més l'Ancien City, que és la ciutat vella, és on tots els estrangers visiten.
Però bueno, sí, jo crec que està bé, tampoc veus edificis molt alts, la gent viu al carrer,
que és el que m'agrada a mi també.
Veus molt de xiquets jugant a futbol al carrer, no hi ha telèfonos.
Sí.
I està molt bé.
Quant portes, visc a Casgar?
Vaig vindre al novembre.
Doncs mira, fa 9 mesos i mig.
Sí, vas vindre al novembre.
10 mesos.
I he estat...
La setmana passada vaig tornar a...
A Espanya, la primera vegada després de 9 mesos o 10 mesos, i vaig vindre a això, farà 6 dies.
Va, la pregunta important, què fas aquí?
Doncs sóc director de futbol.
Director de futbol, quina edat tens? Perquè això jo ho veig com a gent molt gran, no?
Sóc 37, 37 anys.
37, o sigui no tan gran, jove.
Ja, jove.
Havies sigut jugador?
Sí, de fet.
Havies jugat a futbol?
Sí, he jugat 14-15 anys com a professional en l'escola de...
Bueno, jo vaig ser de l'Albaida, i després vaig firmar en el València, on vaig estar 10 anys.
Ostres.
Des de l'infantil fins a...
Vas poder debutar en una Emery, en el primer equip, en Europa League...
Vaig estar mirant la teva Wikipedia ahir, i sortia a València, però aquests d'estades potser no...
Sí, sí, 2009 vaig debutar a Mestalla.
Posarem alguna foto per aquí.
Sí, de fet vaig jugar a grans jocs, com Jordi Alba, molt sants...
Quina posició tenies?
Jo era extrem dret, extrem esquerre.
Davanter, no?
Davanter, ja. Podíem dir que davanter, ja.
Ok, ok.
Molt bé. I després, del València?
Del València vaig acabar contract, vaig anar a l'Alcoyano, per estar més proper de casa.
Això era segona divisió, no?
Segona B.
Segona B, ok.
Sí, de fet, aquell any a segona B, pugem a segona A.
Ah, mira.
Tenim una ascensa a segona A, després no ens renoven, vaig atrevegar proper de casa al Sètiba, a l'Olímpic de Sètiba,
on tinc una lesió grau del turmei.
I paro gairebé un any.
I després, allà, intentant ubicar-me una miqueta en el futbol, vaig a Turquia a provar en equips de Kazakhstan.
Ostres, tu.
No és molt bé, però faig una relació també amb un agent, que em crida d'un dia a l'altre per anar a Bielorússia.
De fet, vaig anar amb un altre espanyol a Bielorússia, vam estar una setmana de prova i els dos vam firmar.
I vam estar una temporada jugant allà.
Molt bé.
I després ja t'he dit, torna a atrevegar a casa, proper a l'Ontinyent, tercera divisió, a mitja temporada marxo a Nicaragua,
i faig una mitja temporada a Nicaragua.
A Nicaragua, tu.
Sí, després ja.
La lliga nicaragüense, eh?
Sí.
Molt bé.
Un poc complicat, però bueno, al final són experiències.
Que també, després d'aquestes lesions, em porta a viatjar pel món, després comença a entrenar.
O sigui, el teu pare és jugador, entrenador i ara director.
Sí, de fet, quan jugava ja entrenava.
Anem, podem seguir recte.
Quan jugava ja entrenava, però era més menudet, per treure la llicència, els cursos, per poder estar federat també.
I, de fet, jo acabé jugant així a Xina, 2018.
Benvingut a una lliga.
Hola.
Doncs això, acabé jugant així a Xina, en una lliga regional i entrenant.
Després ve el Covid, que a mi m'he piat també viatjant per Àsia, no vaig poder tornar a Xina, i després, bueno, he estat en diversos països més també.
En Àfrica he estat tres anys, dirigint també de scouting, buscant jugadors per poder manejar-los a Europa, Costa Rica també.
Xina és un país que no precisament és molt famós pel futbol, i Casgar precisament és la ciutat gran més a l'oest de tota la Xina.
Llavors, com és que aquí tenen necessitat de tenir un...
Un director esportiu estranger?
Sí, doncs jo tampoc coneixia gaire aquesta regió.
De fet, jo a la gent que dic que estic així no la coneixen.
Normalment no coneixen el Shanghai, Beijing, Chongqing, totes aquestes ciutats.
Però, bueno, jo crec que al final jo vinc també recomanat per un altre espanyol que està a Shanghai,
que ell sabia que així necessitaven un director tècnic.
I al final vinc també un poquet per canviar la metodologia, el veure el futbol diferent,
per portar alguna cosa d'Europa, alguna cosa d'Espanya a aquesta regió, perquè al final així...
Jo això ho veig, sobretot aquesta part, més com la d'Àfrica, podríem dir, l'Àfrica de Xina.
El jugador és més físic, el sap molt el córrer, l'apretar...
Llavors jo al final he portat més el treball amb valor, té una estructura, una metodologia...
Llavors estàs en un club en concret?
Estic com en una federació, podríem dir federació,
però és d'aquesta ciutat.
I entrenes a... o sigui, ets director esportiu en general de molts aquí?
Sí, ara hem creat el Sub 10, de deu anyets, però quan vaig vindre teníem de Sub 13 a Sub 17.
Molt bé, i ets l'únic estranger que està en aquest equip, o...?
Sí, en este treball sóc el primer, no sé si estranger o espanyol, de la història en treballar, sí.
He vist algun africà últimament en el TikTok de la ciutat,
he vist algun tiktok de Xina, he vist algun africà.
Clar, Espanya ha guanyat el Mundial, Espanya és un país que té grans equips,
suposo que deus ser... per ells és caché, no?, que un espanyol vingui aquí a ensenyar.
Sí, clar, jo vinc quan Espanya no havia sigut encara el campió d'estiu últim Mundial,
però al final l'Espanya de 2010 que guanya, en el seu tiqui-taca, el control de valor,
ens ajuda molt a nosaltres, als entrenadors, també als jugadors, a poder eixir,
el que el tinguem és valorat, i sí, al final, no sé si pel tema d'esponsos,
també, o anar a tornejos més importants, el tindre algú d'Espanya,
jo crec que així ens dona un poc més de fama, podem dir.
Quan arribes, de seguida pots implementar molts dels teus canvis,
o les teves metodologies i tal, o costa?
Costa, costa molt.
Clar, no parles xinès, imagino.
Clar, no, no, no.
O una mica.
Algunes paraules.
El problema d'ací també, no problema, però ells tampoc gasten molt el xinès ací, gasten el hígur.
Sí.
És molt dialecte.
Val, i tens molts jugadors, entenc que...
Tots.
Tots són hígurs.
Claro, són tots hígurs, i la gent que treballa...
Però hi ha gent que no és hígur, també.
Sí, el tema que Casgar és una ciutat, sobretot ara en la bona temperatura,
que ve molta gent de fora, de fora de Casgar.
Però els futboleros sí, els futboleros sí que són hígurs.
Els futboleros sí, són hígurs.
Vale, vale, vale.
Entonces, ja encontrar algo que parli molt bé el xinès és complicat ací.
Ostres.
Te pots imaginar l'inglés.
No, no.
Entonces, jo sí que tinc la sort que tinc una xica,
que ella és la doctora també del nostre club, que també parla anglès.
Entonces ella està com, podríem dir, 24 hores amb mi, si necessita alguna cosa,
hospitals, comprar, ella està amb mi, i després en l'oficina per explicar els entrenaments,
en el camp tinc una altra xica que també parla anglès, que és professora d'anglès.
La infraestructura és bona, no?
Sí.
Tant personal com d'equipaments.
Sí, és bona.
Costa, i ha d'apretar un poquet perquè al final costa gastar, però el que ell deia,
jo no puc vindre ací i canviar-ho tot en dues setmanes.
Clar, això és el que deia, no?
Que has sigut el primer que has canviat o que has donat més èmfasi per dir-ho?
Al final jo vaig clavar el videoanàlisi, també ací, que no veien...
Al final ell... Podem anar cap allà. És allí, al cantó.
D'acord.
Al final el jugador també... El jugador sempre vol tindre la raó.
Llavors, quan hi ha algun fall i tu intentes explicar, els diuen que no, que no, que ho he fet bé.
Llavors, portar-li el videoanàlisi ací, que ells es veuen en pantalla, poder analitzar... Llavors això és un pas, ja.
Això que dius em sorprèn perquè els xinesos tenen fama de ser gent que segueix molt el que diu el superior.
No sé si els uigurs en aquest sentit són diferents.
Sí, sí, també, però en el tema del futbol quan algú es veu en pantalla ja pots reconèixer que ha fet bé o que ha fet mal.
Però ja el dic, no puc vindre ací i canviar-ho tot.
No, clar.
Però el que hi ha que fer és emmoldar-se.
Llavors jo he fet... Doncs bé, els dono un poc de mà, aquells també em diuen coses i després jo també he ajudat-los en algunes coses.
Al final fem un mix que de fet els resultats estan vingant bé perquè vaig vindre la setmana passada i tinc l'oferta de renovació ara.
Clar, tu has estat a molts llocs diferents, no has estat en llocs que et quedessis molt temps. Aquí t'hi veus quedant-te més temps dels altres o què?
De moment...
De moment estic bé.
Dubtes.
Sí, perquè no se sap mai.
Ja.
Al final demà el cap canvia d'opinió i s'ha acabat.
Sí.
Llavors estic bé, no tinc cap problema. També el tema de l'econòmic està molt bé ací, no estic tenint cap problema.
Estic molt barat.
És molt barat, la vida és molt barata.
Jo vull guanyar, gastar, no puc gastar.
Ostres.
Al final no gastes, no pots gastar perquè ja el dic, vas a dinar dos o tres euros com a molt, bons dinars.
Jo crec que menges molt bé. O sigui, és més barat menjar fora de casa que comprar els productes al supermercat.
Sí, és que...
I la vida és taxis, o ara has pogut comprovar que els taxis també són molt barats, tenen trajectes llargs. La vida és molt tranquil·la, sobretot en esta ciutat és molt tranquil·la. Estic molt bé.
Et vull preguntar què tal l'hivern, perquè clar, aquí s'està molt bé ara mateix de temperatura, però has passat un gener, febrer... Com ha sigut? Fa molt fred o què?
Sí, no... Finals de novembre, desembre, gener, febrer...
Finals de febrer, molt de fred.
Mínims de...?
Mínims quatre...
Bé...
Fa fred, fa fred.
Però bé, sí, fa fred.
Sí, com estan.
Quatre sota ceres tenien, o quatre?
Sí, sota, sota.
Sota, sota.
Al final com estem al costat del desert, també.
Sí.
No sé com explicar, també... És un fred diferent. Estat a Bielorússia, com t'he comentat abans, sota 30.
Ja.
Però és un fred diferent, és com el calor. Ara s'està molt bé, però...
En agost...
És terrible, també.
Sí, eh?
Sí. El fred... També tenim les torments estes d'arena.
Això ve? Arriba a la ciutat?
Sí, sí. És molt complicat, així. De fet, el telèfon no... Jo els primers dos mesos el meu telèfon marcava de no eixir al carrer.
Uau.
Per respirar...
Ostres.
L'ambient no era molt, molt bo, però bueno. Dura un mes o dos mesos i després canvia. A veritat que ara s'està molt, molt bé.
Sí.
El porte ací a dinar és un restaurant prou famós.
Famós, eh?
Sí.
Ok, mira, aquí el tenim.
Menjarem pilau ací dins.
El què? Plou?
Pilou.
Ostres. Vale, vale.
L'has provat molt.
Joder. L'altre dia vaig dir al vídeo que no menjaria mai més plou fa la meva vida.
Sí, però tornem a provar-lo.
És que, clar, jo vinc de Tadjikistan.
Jo també.
Jo cada dia. Cada dia el plou.
Ah, sí?
No, és una barbaritat. És una barbaritat.
Uau, ja han gal·liat.
Ja han gal·liat.
I tothom està dinant.
Tot dinant i tot dinant mateix.
A l'hora. O sigui, entre cometes.
Jo pensava que la gent anirà aquí a les 4 o 5 per...
Vale.
Tots mengen el mateix.
Anem cap allà, anem cap allà.
Plou, eh?
Tornarem a menjar el plou. Bueno.
D'acord, bueno, anem a menjar tranquils i després continuem parlant.
Molt bé.
A veure si pots disfrutar.
De segons diuen és dels millors.
Pilar.
Pilar, ja.
Ah, sí, però també jo crec que té un poc de fama dels vídeos de la gent de...
Ah, la gent que fa una mica viral, eh?
Sí.
A veure si la troba i després...
D'acord, et dic.
Doncs sí que estava bé. Estava bo. Especialment la carn, que a la de Tadjikistan,
el plou que fan a Tadjikistan, la carn està dura i no aquesta estava ben... ben cuidada.
Bueno, gràcies, m'has convidat. Quant ha costat, per curiositat?
Cinquanta-tres, cinquanta-quatre iuans.
O sigui, això són dos i pico per persona?
Sí, jo crec que és sis euros, poc de sis euros, però bueno, al final menges l'arròs...
Jogur i plou.
Sí, l'arròs, la carn... De fet, el que t'he comentat, que l'arròs pots...
és il·limitat, pots repetir i repetir. Crec que és un preu espectacular.
Sí, sí.
La carn està molt bona. És un restaurant... jo crec que s'ha fet viral.
Tampoc és que sigui molt especial, però està bé, per això t'he portat.
I bueno, m'alegra que haig de disfrutar.
I ara m'has portat a un lloc molt guai, que és com aquí un llac, no? Guai?
Sí.
Amb la Nòria de Fons. Molt xulo, per aquí no havia vingut.
Sí. Així també tens l'opció d'alquilar... poden rentar algunes barquetes i passejar, tranquil·litat...
I allà veig que aquesta nit hi haurà alguna cosa, eh?
Sí, veig que hi ha algun concert.
Hi ha algun concert.
Doncs potser vinc.
Sí. És molt bonic. Pots passejar. De fet, per les nits té totes les llums i encara és més bonic que ara.
Però bueno, estàs tranquil·l i s'està bé.
Bueno, tòpic dels xinesos. Són molt treballadors. Anem a confirmar-lo o a desmentir-lo?
Són molt treballadors, però també intenten... el que t'he comentat abans, que quan poden, se poden escapar,
o descansen per a fumar-se el seu cigarret o estar amb el telèfon. Però sí, normal, sí que treballen molt.
Estos empleats són entrenadors, podríem dir, no?
Sí. Són tots entrenadors i alguns també professors. Fan les dues funcions.
Molt bé. Bueno, com has dit que has estat a altres parts de la Xina, quines serien les diferències principals que tu veus entre aquí i altres llocs?
La primera és...
O sigui, per començar, el treu és molt diferent? O sigui, tu veus que és molt diferent?
Sí, sí, sí. Jo crec que sí. T'he comentat també abans el tema de la neteja. Jo crec que esta ciutat no és tan neta com les altres de Xina.
De fet, també l'aparència de les persones, així són més... jo diria com més europeus, la cara.
Després tenen el seu dialecte, que és el hígur. També esta part és musulmana.
I, bueno, jo crec que també, portant tot el meu terreny en el futbol, el jugador és més físic, com t'he comentat abans.
Més físic és a més el córrer que a altres llocs de Xina.
I, però jo què sé, l'arquitectura és molt diferent?
Perquè, clar, és que jo ho veig molt xino. No ho veig molt xinès, això. Tu dius que no.
No, jo crec que esta ciutat també està per... va més lenta a desenvolupar-se, però si te'n vas un poquet més cap a fora, sí que veus que s'estan construint les coses.
Però com veus, jo, en la part on he vist, també les cases són xocotetes. No hi ha estos edificis que veus al Chengdu o al Xi'an, que són més grans.
De fet, jo crec que està per desenvolupar un poquet la ciutat.
Vale, bueno, a qui que són més, del Barça o del Madrid?
Els meus entrenadors, tinc uns 50-50, però no hi són del Barça-Madrid, ningú és del València.
No, clar.
Ningú és de l'Atleti de Madrid. Són molt de Jamal.
Ah, sí?
Tot és Jamal.
Potser, no ho sé.
Doncs no ho sé, jo crec que també pot ser que sigui això. De fet, ara que he estat a Espanya aquesta última setmana, ells volien que es portés camises de Jamal.
Que estiguera amb ell, com si fos fàcil.
El Pounders el coneixes, no?
Sí, però sí, jo crec que un poquet més del Barça. Per Jamal, te diria que per Jamal.
Està bé. Vinc de països que eren molt del Madrid. No ho sé, potser perquè el Ronaldo juga a la Lliga Àrabe i potser el veuen més.
No ho sé.
Potser, potser.
Aquí segueixen molt la Lliga Espanyola?
Sí, sí, sí que la segueixen. El tema dels horaris és un poquet complicat, però també és una altra cosa que jo he de posar més el focus en ells.
Perquè el tema del descans, dels horaris, com que no es respeten, així s'egiten molt tard.
Perquè el que t'he comentat abans és que...
Mira, tinc el braç que se m'està cansant. A veure si ens podem asseure aquí a l'ombra.
Posaré el mòbil aquí. Estrem una mica les fosques, però és que clar, el sol pica molt, eh?
Sí, comença a fer calor.
El sol pica molt.
El tema seguretat. O sigui, hi ha moltes càmeres i tal. A mi, clar, no m'afecta. Jo vaig caminant, m'és igual.
Però aquestes càmeres què són?
Per multes o... No ho sé. T'arriben multes?
Als meus entrenadors s'arriben multes. De tràfic, sobretot. De moto, de cotxe, de tràfic.
Però sí que és una... Jo crec que a la Xina, en general, la seguretat és màxima. No hi ha cap problema.
Jo que he estat també vivint, com t'he comentat, a l'Àfrica, he vist que atraquen la gent al carrer.
Motos que paren, te lleven el bols. Així no pot passar.
Jo crec que també tot es va via la cara. Està tot escanellat.
Està escanellat així. I jo crec que qualsevol coseta que facis saltes com en alguna informació a la policia.
Això no t'afecta, en principi, no? No està sent que et registres.
Bueno, segur que tenen visibilitat, d'alguna manera.
Sí, jo crec que sí. Perquè, com t'he comentat, també és un poc complicat el poder entrar i obtenir el tema de visatge,
residència i treballar. Però bueno, també té les seves coses bones i les seves coses no tan bones.
Tema natura.
O sigui, tu tens temps de tenir algun hobby?
O treballes tant que et costa?
Tinc un hobby, sí. M'agrada molt llegir i després no puc portar-me el futbol.
Vaig a casa i estic ordinador de futbol.
Sí, perquè també he estat ajudant algunes agències en jugadors.
Veig molt la Lliga de Colòmbia, la primera i la segona divisió.
I després el tema d'Àfrica, perquè com que està vivint també allí, doncs tinc connexions.
M'ha costat molt desconnectar, però m'agrada molt tindre la moto i pegar una volteta.
També llegir i estar un poc tranquil quan tinc temps.
Però passa molt de temps en la feina.
Aquesta gent que mireu tants partits de futbol sempre m'ha preguntat si els mireu sencers,
si mireu com el resum, si aneu fent esquí.
És massa temps, és una hora i mitja.
Sí, depèn. Si tens algun jugador exacte que veure, sí que pots veure tot el partit.
Perquè al final el jugador que tu estàs veient no només és quant té valor,
sinó és com funciona quan no té valor en tots els aspectes del joc.
Llavors sí que veus tot el partit.
Però hi ha vegades que has de veure per damunt, sí que li apretes el 2x, que va un poc més ràpid.
Has rebut alguna visita ja d'algun amic, família aquí a Xinjiang?
De moment no.
Els costa venir?
Jo crec que sí. Els meus pares sí que ara estan retirats els dos.
Estan viatjant, de fet ara van a Egipte.
Vull portar-los ací, però crec que jo he d'anar allí
per poder portar-los ací.
Perquè el vol directe d'Europa ací no entra.
Passes a Chengdu, vols a Chengdu, com 5 hores te passes casgat i després tornes cap arreu.
Fer aquest tràmit potser és complicat per alguna persona que no parla de res.
Si fos directe, sí que vas a Madrid i ja estàs ací en casgat.
Però com que has de fer algun trasbord o un transfer, és un poc complicat.
Però m'agradaria, sí.
Has vist algun espanyol o sud-americà fins d'un dia?
Vull dir, algú que parli la teva llengua que visqui aquí?
No.
No has conegut ningú?
No, no, no. De fet, és el primer espanyol que puc...
Ara?
Sí, que podem parlar. Però sí que hi ha algun africà, com t'he comentat,
en el tema de la música, que sí que ve dos o tres mesos a treballar ací i després marxa.
Però jo crec que poc espanyol, jo crec que no.
No sé, potser sí que hi ha hagut algú, però tampoc m'he enterat.
Tot el tema tele, música xinesa, suposo que això no ho toques d'aire, no?
No, de fet no tinc...
És que és tot un món com molt tancat amb ell, no? És difícil entrar-hi, potser.
Sí, de fet jo tampoc tinc la televisió a casa.
No, tinc l'ordinador que va a la VPN que m'ha connectat a Europa per poder fer...
Bàsic, bàsic.
Sí, que a vegades dona problemes, també, però de la televisió xina,
del canal xinès que jo busque en l'ordinador és per vore futbol,
que el tinc ja localitzat i veig, perquè tampoc entenc l'idioma,
no vaig a ficar vore pel·lícules tampoc.
A veure, alguna cosa més que t'hagis sorprès tant d'aquí com d'altres llocs de la Xina
que no t'esperaves, no ho sé...
Ah, sí, jo que podríem dir lo dels animals. Vore tant d'animal al carrer.
Animal al carrer viu, mort o de totes maneres?
Viu i mort i...
I això per qui no ho ha vist, potser és més a les afores, no ho sé.
Allí ho he vist jo, sí que ho he vist, sí. Molta carnisseria i portar la cabra...
És curiós, perquè jo me'l sé de matí, vaig a la feina i veig la cabra en la seva cordeta contenta
allà a la porta, i quan torne a les set o les vuit de la tarda, saps que veus el cap.
Ostres... I el deixen al carrer, eh?
El deixen al carrer.
Que ara no fa precisament fred, vull dir que...
L'oneta deu fer, m'imagino, no?
Jo no he notat molt d'olor, però sí que la deixen al carrer.
De fet, has estat en el mercat dels animals, també...
Sí, clar, però allà ja se suposa. Sí, sí, sí.
Aquí també es pot menjar molt menjar xinès. Quin és el teu propi preferit de menjar que no sigui uigur?
A mi m'agraden molt els noodles, els noodles amb la carn.
Sí, molt bo. I després el que hem menjat avui, que també...
Sí.
Però jo tinc molt per noodles i molt d'arròs mesclat amb verdura, amb ou també, molt d'ou...
Diries que és una bona dieta per algú que fa esport, una dieta de menjar xinès?
Vull dir, creus que menja ençà o...?
Sí, jo crec que sí, en aquest lloc sí.
Sí, crec que està molt bé. Com tota la xina, al final és tot noodles i tot arròs.
No hi ha tanta grassa, potser en els olis que gastem ells, que gastem molta manteca i coses d'aquestes.
No, el plou té molt d'oli. Sí. Sí, saco.
Però està bé, hi ha molta verdura en els plats, la fruita, especialment la fruita d'així de casgar, diuen que és molt gustosa.
La figa aquesta és molt bona. La figa molt bona.
Té una figa que és com diferent a la nostra. Sí.
A mi la nostra no m'acaba d'agradar, però aquesta sí.
Jo, de fet, on visc, a Albaida, tenim diverses figueres i està molt bona.
Així la preparen molt diferent. T'agafen la figa i te les trauen.
A Albaida normal? No, la meva és, l'agafes i l'obres i te la menges.
Val. No sé, potser en Espanya o en altres llocs.
Però així com te la aplasten, de fet tenen un ritual que és com dos o tres vegades i te l'obren més en xafaeta.
Però sí, la fruita és molt bona. El mango també molt bo, sí.
Però el mango no s'organitza aquí. No, no crec que hi hagi.
Jo per les aplicacions me demanen molt de mix d'aquestes de fruita i està molt bo.
Llavors, que tens poca vida social, tu creus que...
creant un altre lloc de la Xina, jo què sé, podries seguir vivint en aquest país?
Sí, sí, sí. És la tercera vegada que estic a la Xina. A mi m'agrada molt.
Sí que el futbol va més lent que en altres llocs, però el talent és més complicat d'encontrar a la Xina.
Però estic bé. Al final, també el tema dels pagaments del salari, que tot siga...
Millor que a Àfrica, segur. Sí. No hi hagi retrasos i que paguen i que siguin segurs.
Però estic obert també a altres opcions que puguin existir.
Si haguessis d'escollir, tu pots escollir un lloc que no sigui Europa, per això, per fer de director.
Ignorem els diners ara, en algun moment. On t'agradaria entrenar o fer de director? De scout o el que sigui.
Jo crec que la Xina no seria dels llocs que elegiria. Pot ser Àfrica. Àfrica m'agrada molt, sí, perquè al final...
El jugador... Juga molt al carrer. És una via d'escapa que tenim per poder eixir de la seva família, dels problemes que podem tindre,
perquè és molt pobre en els llocs, i veus molt de talent, que necessiten ajuda. Però, clar, també Àfrica té això.
Que te podem pagar, que no te podem pagar. No sé si m'ho has dit abans. Quin país havies estat, a l'Àfrica?
He estat a Camerún i he estat a Quènia.
Camerún i Quènia... Camerún sí que havia sigut una potència quan hi havia l'Eto'o. L'Eto'o, sí.
Però ara Quènia i Camerún no van estar ni al Mundial. No, no, no, no. Tenen molts bons jugadors, però jo crec que no tenen molt bons equips.
Sí, Eto'o... De fet, jo on treballava en Camerún, l'acadèmia és d'on és Eto'o. A Eto'o el meu germà li deia papa, que és el que el va portar al Madrid.
És l'acadèmia de Katzi. I Quènia és més famosa per l'atletisme, jo crec.
Sí.
Al final, també, quan estava allí, veies tots córrer i córrer i córrer i córrer.
Les dies potents de bàsquet són l'Egipte i Sud-àfrica, potser? No en sé gaire, però...
Egipte molt bé, sí. Egipte té... I després ja n'hi ha algun a Senegal, està molt bé. Gana està en potència, també.
Bé...
Àfrica està molt bé. Té molt...
No aniré a Àfrica.
No aniré a Àfrica. Però, bueno... Molt bé, tu. Doncs crec que se m'acaben les preguntes. No sé si em vols explicar alguna cosa.
No, no res més.
Doncs espero que gaudis d'aquesta ciutat, que t'arreglin el visat i pugues, també, seguir el teu camí.
I que tinguis sort, també, i que t'acompanyin les cames.
Sí.
Això és dur, és molt dur. I, bueno, que... Gràcies, també, per l'entrevista.
Res, a tu. Moltes gràcies. Vinga, un plaer.
Un plaer.
A la propera.
Adeu.